good afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice president and Dean where
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
welcome to the Allenby Kirby center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
most of you know what we try to do here
in Washington see is the college is to
teach and one of the most important
things to teach in this town especially
is to teach people who want to learn
about statecraft and the art of
statesmanship the best way to do that is
to study great statesman which we do in
our classes and we do in our activities
and retreats we do for members of
Congress on a regular basis and we guest
here today is going to talk about that
some of the two of the greatest of those
statesman and what we could learn from
them he's one of our professors one of
our fine professors who I know quite
well to introduce our speaker today a
student Emily Runge will be introducing
him she is a junior politics major back
home campus Hillsdale she's currently
interning on our whip program in the
asian studies center of the heritage
foundation on campus she's a george
washington fellow she's a student
assistant the president's office she's
with the pi beta phi sorority and after
graduation she's going to consider going
abroad to teach for a year before she
goes on to graduate school so I'm like
you'd like to introduce Esther Morris
thank you dr. Spalding doctor will Morsi
holds the William and Patricia lomotil
chair in the United States Constitution
at Hillsdale College where he has taught
since 2000 previously he served as
executive director of the Monmouth
County New Jersey historical commission
and as the legislative aide for the new
jersey state senator thomas gagliano
horse he received his BA from kenyon
college and his MA and PhD from The New
School for Social Research we received
the henna our errand Memorial Award and
politic for his dissertation on the
political thought of the American
presidents of the founding and Civil War
periods Morsi is the author of eight
books on statesmanship and political
philosophy including reflections
on de Gaulle the self government the
American theme presidents of the
founding in civil war the dilemma of
progressivism how Roosevelt Taft and
Wilson reshaped the American regime of
self-government and most recently
Churchill and de Gaulle the geopolitics
of Liberty his articles and books
reviews have been have appeared in The
New York Times The Washington Times the
american political science review the
claremont review of books in an
interpretation a journal of political
philosophy which he has served as an
editor since 1979 please join me in
welcoming dr. bull Morsi thanks for
coming out today and thank you Emily and
thank you Matt what Winston Churchill
and charles de gaulle can teach us about
the world and what they taught their
contemporaries was that there can be
such a thing as a geopolitics of Liberty
that isn't self-evidently so geopolitics
is the realm of necessity politics is or
at least can be the realm of Liberty and
statesmen really adjust the one to the
other Churchill and de Gaulle both
thought so and today I mean to show why
they did and how they conceived of doing
so but first I need to define some terms
namely Liberty jeem states and
geopolitics by Liberty I mean politics
in Aristotle's strict sense of the word
Aristotle compares politics to the
relationship in a household between a
husband and a wife a relationship of
reciprocity of shared rule of ruling and
being ruled in turn he contrasts such
rule of such kinds of of this rule with
such kinds of command and obey rule seen
in the household the rule of parents
over children and have masters / Slade's
the latter two forms of rule
differ from each other in that the
parents rule for the good of the
children whereas of course the Masters
rule for the good of the Masters but
neither of these forms of rule rises to
the level of political rule which is the
rule of persons obligated by consent to
listen to one another to deliberate
together Liberty in the political
community consists of exactly such rule
among the regime's possible in the
palace kingship and aristocracy resemble
rental rule whereas tyranny oligarchy
and democracy resemble masterly rule his
idea of democracy of course is that it's
the many who are poor who are squeezing
and terrorizing the few who are rich the
Republic or mixed regime so structured
that the few who are rich and the many
who are poor must listen to one another
and win each other's consent to the laws
they wish to enact admits genuine
political Liberty Republic's exhibit
political liberal it achill rule to the
highest degree so that's what i mean by
liberty what's a regime it consists and
again i'm following aerosol here first
of the rulers the one the few the many
good or bad second institutions or forms
the rulers frame in order to conduct the
business of ruling third the ways of
life that ruling and being ruled foster
in the citizens and finally the overall
purpose of that way of life so for
example America the purpose of the
regime as the Declaration of
Independence says is to secure the
unalienable rights of life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness a person who
lives under tyrannical rule will live a
life very different than the one who
would live in a commercial Republic he
will learn to love and to fear different
things his soul is likely to be
permanently marked
by those have visual loves and fears
taken together these four elements of
the regime form the ethos or character
of the people who live in the political
community those who found new regimes or
reform old ones take care to see that
the rulers ruling institutions ways of
life and overall purpose of the
community all reinforce one another form
a coherent whole when you attack foreign
regimes or defend your own regime
against foreign attack you must
coordinate all these elements in a
sustained effort organized in the most
desperate circumstances as statesmen
Churchill and you all face this question
of regimes in exactly such circumstances
the modern commercial Republic's
confronted the military oligarchies of
vilhelm on Germany and austria-hungary
then the tyranny is of Nazi Germany and
fascist Italy and then again with
nuclear weapons on both sides the
tyranny and eventually the oligarchy of
the soviet union in prevailing against
these illiberal regimes republics proved
the defense of political Liberty hard
but also possible what's more Churchill
de Gaulle and the Statesman politicians
and tyrants they encountered all acted
in a world of massive centralized modern
states the third term I want to define
by States as distinguished from regimes
I mean political communities understood
not in terms of who rules but in terms
of the sides and the degree of
centralization of the government
structures for example whatever regime
it may have Apollo's an ancient Palace
is small and centralized a feudal state
larger but decentralized a modern state
large and centralized an empire is very
large but often quite decentralized the
modern States Churchill and to go all
saw
tended not only for territory not only
for rule over vast populations they also
contended with rival regimes and rival
state forms some of these states had
regimes that aimed not at self-defense
or even regional hegemony but at
worldwide rule given enemies animated by
such ambitions defenders of the
commercial Republic's needed to attend
not only two regimes and states but
would it come to be called in their
lifetimes geopolitics the fourth term
that I wanted to find as the word
implies students of geopolitics overlay
the boundaries of states and their
regimes on the geography of the earth
the geography of one's own country
amounts to a stubborn fact changeable by
military or demographic conquest but not
easily changed geography is nature
without natural right natural right and
a political liberties that secure it
must themselves be secured not only by
regimes but by policies that defend
citizens by defending the key physical
approaches to their territory all men
may be created equal but all terrains
are not the Strait of Gibraltar the
mouth of the Mississippi River the
english channel such geographic choke
points must figure in the military
political and economic thinking of any
nearby ruler although contemporaries
Churchill and ago all faced different
geopolitical circumstances in the first
half of the 20th century the capital
city of the British regime sat on a
medium-sized island but it ruled some
twenty percent of the human race and
roughly twenty-five percent of the land
on earth although it did not rule the
Seas with quite the authority it had
enjoyed in the 19th century it still had
the best Navy in the world it had
substantial military material and
technological resources to augment its
well settled regime
of political liberty and it needed them
all and it's two wars with Germany
France occupied a larger homeland but
ruled a much smaller empire although
equally far-flung its position was more
vulnerable than that of Great Britain
with its capital city on the western
part section of the European plain that
vast flat land that extends from the
Atlantic Ocean to the Ural Mountains in
Russia although Frances coastlines offer
its suburb access to major trade routes
and imperial holdings and while seas
oceans and mountains give France
security on most of its borders it
remains geographically open to invasion
from the west from whoever controls
germinate now this causes a political
problem for France it's not just a
geopolitical problem to defend their
capital the French need a substantial
army as every good Republican used to
know armies can threaten Republican
regimes in a way that navies for example
do not armies can stage kuz d'etat
against civilian government french
geography thus makes both the French
state and French Republican more as the
French say problematique what about the
geopolitical circumstances of the
enemies of Great Britain and France with
the sole advantage of vastness Russia
its capital on the western section of
the country obviously faces the mirror
image of France's dilemma vulnerable not
from the east but from the West Germany
the other 20th century enemy of great
britain and france found itself in a
double vine vulnerable from the east and
from the west its political antidote to
such vulnerability is marc ian state
centralization under regimes of military
oligarchy or of militant tyranny let it
into not out of is surrounding Maelstrom
in addition to these enemies
indigo also saw the rise what Ave Ave
friendly but worrisome regime in North
America one which had never wielded the
worldwide influence it partly fell into
but mostly intended and successfully
planned or as they could and did predict
the conduct of Imperial Germany Nazi
Germany in the Soviet Union these
statesmen could not eat so easily
anticipate American conduct they merit
very much would have liked to have
guided it in any to any degree possible
they both needed but to a degree dreaded
the United States and some of its
policies especially those arising from
the Americans long-standing hostility to
European imperialism British and French
statesmen needed to bring all these
matters regime state politics technology
into coherent strategies of self-defense
now all three of the major enemy regimes
bill helm on Germany Nazi Germany Soviet
Union enjoyed the military advantages
that military oligarchy and tyranny
often wield a sustained program of
military organization and procurement in
addition to the ability to prepare
secretly and to strike suddenly the
enemy states also had large populations
at their disposal populations his
attention could be commanded by
propaganda channeled through
communications media rulers and troll to
counter these advantages Churchill and
de Gaulle urged peace-loving commercial
Republican citizens to prepare
militarily they also sought alliances
with regimes that shared their sense of
these dangers and wanted to contain or
eliminate them these similarities
notwithstanding the two statesmen found
themselves in rather different
circumstances geographically and
politically and proceeded accordingly
now Hector on all sides by what are the
British Isles in Churchill's time
commanded the aforementioned worldwide
higher but this Empire was not so
compact as the nazi and soviet empire
not composed as theirs were of
geographically contiguous territories
therefore Churchill's Navy based
strategy not only defended the home
island but also sought to keep extended
and vulnerable supply and communications
routes open because his country's most
important enemies lived in Europe
Churchill could continue Great Britain's
long-standing policy of offshore
balancing opposing each bidder for
continental empires it arose this was
then supplemented by occasional onshore
balancing with land troops as needed
this was a strategy not of divide and
rule that was reserved for ruling the
peoples within the empire but of divide
and deflect this need for offshore
balancing and also for alliances and for
the maintenance of an overseas and
overseas Empire all explained
Churchill's preference for military
political strategies that emphasized
encirclement in Direction taking the end
around most famously his persistent
attempts to get at Germany from the
south from the Dardanelle straits now
politically at home Churchill enjoyed
the advantage not only of a
long-established Imperial state but a
long Steve a long stable regime that
accustomed its people to a civic and
political life to the responsibilities
of ruling and being ruled which
responsibilities in turn gave them
reason to defend themselves and their
regime against foreign oligarchs and
tyrants however the regime had changed
considerably in the past 100 years
moving from a mixed regime in which the
monarch titled aristocrats and
mercantile oligarchs shared Authority
with some of the middle classes to a
much more nearly democratic commercial
republic in which every man and soon
woman voted how would that kind of
commercial Republic fair when confronted
with hard foreign policy choices could
it avoid the traditional isolationism of
the Conservatives and the anti
militarism of the Liberals with the new
socialists defend their country not only
against their obvious ouran enemies on
the right but against the blandishments
of the international left this
circumstance accounts for Churchill's
voluminous writings which amount to
nothing less than a vast one-man effort
to provide his countrymen with a sort of
civic education that men of his class
the aristocracy had had bred into them
through the system of classical schools
which introduced students to the
literature of the Greeks and Romans a
literature that in large measure is
devoted to understanding politics
Churchill exhibits strong traces of lat
inity of Roman nuts in his very
anglo-saxon ISM if the people now voted
but could not attend herro or Sandhurst
they could hear Churchill speeches and
read the world crisis life of
Marlborough the Second World War unlike
books for scholarly audiences
Churchill's writings teach politics by
telling stories they are better than
most popular novels they present the
history of England of the English as a
vast working out of the questions of
self-defense civil freedom and statism
in a commercial Republic these writings
could also find a readership in the vast
commercial Republic that shared the
English language and the Atlantic Ocean
with the British Navy and with British
commercial shipping even if the Empire
even if the Empire could not be
perpetuated and of course in the end it
could not with a European Confederation
of commercial Republican states what
church will call the United States
yer it could that could work best if
Prudential or statesman like thinking of
of European lat initi could better
inform the somewhat raw Americans even
as the Greeks it advised young Rome the
Alliance could counter the Empire's of
Germany of the Germans and the Russians
in Warren and peace Churchill could
foster an imperial and aristocratic view
of the world without needing imperialism
or aristocrats that is he could
encourage the now sovereign peoples of
Great Britain in the United States to
think of their struggles with their
enemies both in the long term which is
the way aristocrats thing and in the
world as a whole as imperialists thing
conceiving of wars hot and cold as if
they were one big battle fought on land
air and sea but above all fought for
their own peoples and their own ways of
life goal had a different circumstance
to consider there was what he called the
been I'll observation but also a true
one that England was an island in France
was not the French must always worried
about their neighbors to the east this
means that whether France inclines
toward a regime of republicanism or one
of monarchism it will need an
aristocratic or military element
integrated into that regime no purely
commercial republicanism will do unless
France could settle the German question
the Polish question and the Russian
question simultaneously because a
substantial military can endanger any
civilian regime French politics featured
a certain tension not seen in the more
favorably circumstance Great Britain and
United States therefore in a way the
main geopolitical problem de Gaulle
faced rested squarely on the political
problems at home a problem more acute
than that
which trishul faced he saw this early
and he never forgot it Frances political
identity its regime were perennial e
controversial regime and stability
factionalism led not only to unsteady
foreign policy but to opportunities for
exploitation by foreign enemies you go
all proposed to solve the problem a
long-standing problem of regime politics
in France by retaining the republicanism
that had settled in since eighteen
seventy but at the same time getting rid
of parliamentarism by supplementing the
French assembly with a strong executive
branch elected by the people as a whole
a president who could make decisions and
stick with them that was the only
salvation for French republicanism
internally and in its relations with the
world parliamentary republicanism
oscillated between too much talk with no
action and brash imprudent action the
founding soldier statesman of what would
be the fifth republic thought his own
character could provide a model for what
France needed in large measure he was
right about himself although too
optimistic about any of the French to
prepare this founding de Gaulle could
point to the nearby bad example German
moral and political extremism the result
of badly designed regimes animated by
dangerous philosophic principles against
this and against the homegrown
immoderation of French politics de
Gaulle could point to Frances lat inity
the core of which was Missouri or
moderation the virtue which alone could
begin to balance all of France's
contending regime factions in one
Republic geopolitically this Republic
could proceed by getting rid of its
imperial holdings and turning to a
limited rather than an expansionist
nationalism again in noticeable contrast
to the German
the first half of the century and the
Russians of the second half by
criticizing the non-latin non-roman
foreign regimes you go all could
persuade his country nor might persuade
his countrymen to begin to review their
own vices as foreign and disastrous like
Churchill dugal took his speeches as
instances of civic education calling
himself a teacher as his father had been
he's comparable and contrasting
circumstances can be seen in the two
Statesman's account of the First World
War Churchill served in the British
Cabinet understood the war as a crisis
of political liberalism and of the moral
principles that undergirded it the
crisis had two dimensions the
ruthlessness with which all sides now
fought wars in which civilians
participated in the war effort
manufacturing the technologically
advanced weapons that made it possible
to target those very populations put
into question the humanitarianism that
had animated so much of the moral
discourse of the past century also the
profound failure of human predictive
powers seen in the frustration of
well-planned offensive strikes and the
subsequent bogging down of the soldiers
and defensive entrenchments where they
served as passive targets for machine
gunners and long-range artillery
barrages wounded the confidence of men
had had in foreseeable progress which
had been another moral and intellectual
hallmark of previous century
geopolitically however the war was not
at all unprecedented resembling those
great group those that Great Britain had
fought many times before in this new
contest with a continental tyrant a
tyranny had the initiative because
because commercial republic seldom
initiate Wars but the spot but the
civilian control of the war
seen in the republic's entailed a
long-term advantage those government's
Churchill rights were not under moral or
of professional authority when it came
to military decisions elected officials
probed and sometimes countermanded the
recommendations of the generals the
generals knowing and accepting this
authority had reason to lay out their
reasons for doing what they wanted to do
in other words that was ruling and being
ruled it was a political relationship
republicanism also attracted as it
happened a key and in the end decisive
ally the United States which could enter
the war under the banner of defense of
democracy that is under the banner of
the very moral principles and political
principles that the war called into
question among Europeans meanwhile the
Bismarck Ian millichap monarchy come
military oligarchy of Germany consisted
of adventurers who underestimated the
Republic's narrowly military and outlook
the German rulers went to war with a
weak alliance structure and eventually
found themselves out gun but the
Republic's botched the peace affecting
only a superficial regime change in
Germany they also failed to crush the
new left-wing oligarchy that ruled
russia with Germans still outnumbering
the French on the continent and with
France the principal battle site of the
war weakened gun-shy Republican of
victory proved hollow you goals spent
the war on the battlefield and in prison
camps after the war he became the
protégé of a French hero marshal bleep
bleep head Tom a circumstance which
advanced his career but required of him
considerable circumspection when it came
to public political commentary he
confined himself to a veiled political
analysis of France presented as a
military analysis of Germany in his book
by discard shalani me which my colleague
Robert
Eden that Hillsdale College has
translated as the enemy's house divided
the gall independently came to the same
conclusion that Churchill had advanced
concerning the German regime considering
it ill-designed racked with factionalism
because a set of passionate am bc or
intoxicated by ill asim assimilated
drafts of nietzsche competed for
preeminence and eventually set up a
military dictatorship such a regime only
magnified the personal conflicts that
occurred within its narrow circle
Germany's principal ally austria-hungary
was too heterogeneous Malta a
multicultural mess an empire further
deranged by the pressures of war instead
of being united by that this sharp
discord a sharp critique of the discord
in the house of the enemy gives de
Gaulle the literary equivalent of a
military cover for an equally stinging
if much shorter assessment of the French
and their regime if the impatient
overactive overreaching military
oligarchs of Germany we're stymie by
being slowed down in trench warfare the
chattering do nothing French
parliamentarians needed exactly the
opposite they needed energy and an
appreciation for military mobility
coupled he says with the art of the real
and of the possible if the Germans were
faust yet in the beginning was the act
the French were ham lecien that is
indecisive living in a world of words
thanks to cynical old lemans oh and a
military sobriety of Peyton and jofre
yet French outlasted the Germans but no
sooner did they win then they return to
parliamentarism and the ways of life
that made a second war possible for de
Gaulle in contrast to Churchill the
aftermath of the Great War was less a
story of a botched international order
then of a faulty regime
in France a regime that prevented France
from becoming the anchor of a stable
order of nations in Europe digo all
understood parliamentary republicanism
as a regime lacking in one preeminent
moral and political virtue
responsibilities parliamentarians could
hide the behind numbers blaming one
another for their collective incapacity
to act in defense of the country only a
unitary executive who's at words and
actions could be scrutinized by the
sovereign people could be held
responsible could think himself to be
responsible for France without that
France became irresponsible Germany rose
again with a worse regime than ever now
the statesmanship of Churchill and to go
all in the Second World War which both
men regarded as the second phase of a
thirty years war is well known briefly
by his alliances with the United States
and the Soviet Union Churchill saved
Great Britain's regime of liberty but
was forced to begin the devolution of
its state the Empire which he called the
Great the foundation of our greatness to
save Britain he had to sacrifice great
Bitan greatly by contrast de Gaulle
gained much for France in the war if
only because France had lost almost
everything at the beginning of it what
he did gain was crucial for France in
you and for Europe and very seldom
understood in America de Gaulle used the
war to reconstitute the French state
with a Republican regime rather than one
dominated by the communist party without
de gaulle's clandestine operations in
France before d-day in the years when he
was running a government in exile in
london and algiers he only organized
forces in france after nazi defeat would
have been the French Communist Party and
the Allied armies with the latter
needing urgently to press on to Berlin
in the aftermath of that war he's now
eminent statesmen faced a new enemy in a
new kind of war the Cold War Cold War
enemy of the regime of Liberty the
Soviet Union avoided German rashness for
his country Churchill saw several ways
to proceed simultaneously as a naval
power the United Kingdom could
collaborate with the United States to
retain control of the North Atlantic sea
lanes which had proved his country's
lifelines during the world wars and
would be the lifelines of NATO in the
Cold War he could also fight to retain
what remained of the British imperial
possessions in the Mediterranean from
Gibraltar to the Suez Canal a foundation
of containing Germany and Russia in
southern Europe partly in view of Soviet
refusal to hold real elections in Poland
after the war Churchill adjusted his too
generous wartime opinion of Stalin
recurring to his to his original
perception of the regime dating from
right around the time of its founding
that ideology more than Russian national
interests drove Soviet policy in this
new war there was still at least some
need to drag the Americans in a need to
be that began to be accomplished at
Bolton Missouri with the iron curtain
speech the actual title of that speech
as you know was the sinews of peace and
it only over States matters some to say
that in the Cold War Churchill hoped the
Americans would provide the sinews of
peace while he and his fellow British
statesman lent their brains to the
operation he saw hope he saw hope also
in the character of the very Soviet
ideology that made the Soviets dangerous
it was he judged too unnatural
put-putting to severe strains upon human
beings were to survive for long as the
hold of both Soviet ideology and the
regime weakened date aunt could become
possible now neither Truman or President
Eisenhower
retreated from Roosevelt's
anti-imperialist position throughout his
second administration Churchill clung
Great Britain's remaining imperial
holdings but looking to the future he
also advocated redeploying British
forces from the Imperial territories to
Europe in order to lessen NATO's
reliance on the United States and its
atomic weapons he correctly foresaw that
the new much more powerful hydrogen
bombs increased increased the chances
for peace and therefore eventual Soviet
softening and International Date aunt
because unlike the Hiroshima era bombs
the hydrogen bombs really could be used
to destroy a large country in toto such
a prospect sobered even the ideologues
of the Kremlin he put little stock in
the United Nations Organization judging
it at once too broad and to
factionalized to be of much use in
defending countries attacked by the
Soviets and/or their allies he wanted to
supplement the UN with regional
Federation's the United States of Europe
which for example which which would have
had a much greater interest in
responding promptly and prudently to
local crises yet for United States of
Europe to occur franco-german
partnership was necessary first with a
European trade union a European
Federation and an 80 with increased
European participation all in hand
Churchill projected the commercial
republics of the West could defend
themselves and prosper while waiting for
the decline of the Soviet empire now de
gaulle's strategy for some resemblance
to this but with a sharper edge and more
insistent Eurocentrism because de Gaulle
had decided to get rid of the French
Empire he didn't face Churchill's
dilemma in fact he could deploy the
principle of national
determination against both imperialism
the Soviet Union and hegemony the United
States in as much as both superpowers
had made much of the imperialism of the
Europeans decolonization could counter
that rhetoric and turn it against its
sponsors to go all envisioned what he
called Old Europe mr. Rumsfeld did not
invent that word he envisioned all
Europe as a moderating influence of
balancer between the two new worlds as
he called them dominated by America and
Russia to reach to achieve a renewal of
Old Europe you all needed first to
refound French republicanism this time
he succeeded armed with real executive
authority de Gaulle could then conduct
national foreign policies nonetheless
intending to advance the greater
interests of the world as such because
based upon Liberty egalitarians for
itself self-government in the full sense
of the word given this nationalism with
a human face you go I'll never made
France quite neutral in the cold war
while at the same time often harshly
exhibiting independence of judgment in
action by formally if not in for by
formally if not informally with growing
from NATO and by criticizing American
leadership of the West on issues ranging
from monetary policy to the conduct of
Vietnam War but he to practice tech
policy of containing the Soviets by
reaching out to Maoist China
diplomatically and especially by his
civilisational appeals to lat inity he
made that rapprochement with Germany
with Konrad Adenauer in the 50s and one
of the basis of it was that add an hour
was a rhinelander athleta he could have
him over it to his home om Bay Lake does
egli it's not just meet him at the
alizee palace so out of NATO but in
collaboration with Nate
backed with an independent nuclear
arsenal you go always confident that he
could face down any further Soviet
poaching in Europe lat initi had the
advantage of reinforcing french cultural
patriotism while distinguishing france
in a wide variety of christian and prada
and orthodox of a Protestant Christian
Protestant and Orthodox heritage I
Protestant an Orthodox Christianity not
coincidentally Russia and the
anglo-americans this Latin core which
include Catholic southern Germany could
he hoped decisively influenced his own
version of a European Federation not the
United States of Europe in the sense of
a federation with a sovereign center but
a federation more along the lines
sketched by Montesquieu a federation of
self-governing Republic's such a
federation could include Britain if if
it renounced its lattice ISM that is its
special relationship with United States
and Canada meanwhile the Latin
inflection of the Federation could link
itself with South and Central America
and two other former colonies of the
French and Spanish empires in Africa and
Asia Churchill and de Gaulle repeatedly
recurred to the classical and Biblical
core of the West is the touchstone for
all their policies while neither
denigrating the wisdom seen in other
civilizations nor imagining that a
citizen of any country within the West
should approach that civilization
through any culture but his own
initially in the aftermath of the Second
World War Churchill told students at the
University of Oslo he who has received a
university training possesses a rich
choice he need never be inactive or
bored there is no reason for him to seek
refuge in the plaque and clatter of
modern life he need not be dependent on
headlines which give him something new
every day he has the wisdom of all time
bring from and to enjoy as long as he
lives gradually as I have passed through
life I've developed a strong feeling
that a university training should not be
too practical in its aims young people
study at universities to achieve
knowledge not to earn learn a trade we
must all learn how to support ourselves
but we must also learn how to live we
need a lot of engineers in the modern
world but we do not want a world of of
modern engineers we all enjoy freedom
freedom for all this is the most vital
question of the future the
accomplishment of Christian ethics in
our daily life is the final and greatest
word which has ever been said only on
this basis can we reconcile the rights
of the individual with the demands of
society in a matter which alone can
bring happiness and east to humanity
Churchill died just before the students
in the universities of the West began an
assault on just this kind of education
you go all did see that assault and at
its most virulent in the streets of
Paris in May 1968 and students joined
with workers in an attempt to overthrow
the Fifth Republic he faced down that
challenge by offering concessions to the
workers and splitting them from the
students but the students antics
disheartened him he had hoped that the
regime he had founded would influence
the moral and political sensibilities of
the first generation that came up in it
quite the opposite later he told his his
culture minister the great novelist
Andre Malraux the students drama is not
a drama of the university is a crisis of
civilization you see there is something
that cannot go on the irresponsibility
of intellect either that will stop or
Western civilization will stop
montesquieu would have told me something
important but when I have questioned our
intellectuals they have said things that
were simply inconsequential now
stupidity can talk and say nothing
intelligence cannot you will see the
intellectuals must rediscover but they
think when mal
Rowe observed in a hundred years time
who will be able to a tolerant the
vocabulary of the academic left without
laughing alienation structure
demystification Malthusian forces
progressivism consumers civilization to
go all reply that I came to deliver
France from the fantasies that hindered
her from being France character is above
all the ability to disregard insults or
abandonment by one's own people the
classical education it had formed a goal
and Churchill pitted their souls for
steaming such character would subsequent
generations no longer so formed even
comprehend them they might if that kind
of education really does address
permanent aspects of human life its
nature and the political regimes founded
in light of that nature modish academic
jargon will pass the purpose of the box
like these is to put such jargon aside
and to consider statesmen attentive to
the real as they understood themselves
thanks for listening
steward reuter he in your talk you
didn't mention something I think is true
that Churchill and de Gaulle hated each
other oh no actually they didn't they
argued they were these are two highly
spirited men right what Plato calls the
thematic part of the soul as well
exhibited in both of these gentlemen
they didn't hate each other though they
they argued primarily over this they
argued during the war over what de
Gaulle regarded as British encroachments
on French Imperial possessions the goal
had already seen that the French Empire
was going down hill he'd been posted in
Syria in the early 30s and one of his
letters back home he said he tells I
think it's his wife or one of his
friends uh we really haven't made much
of an impression here this is not going
to work um well he was never and this
was true in the Algerian crisis which he
fought which he met in the first years
of his of his tenure he was he was never
going to let an inch of French territory
go without the consent of France would
never do that so if if Churchill was
trying to run troops through Syria or
through some place during the war you go
all would have a fit and now do my uncle
I don't know is that during the war
during the war Churchill did his best to
cut de Gaulle out of any decision-making
uh that was Roosevelt Roosevelt was the
one who Roosevelt really did detest the
Gulf he thought he was going he thought
to go all was going to be another sort
of a military takeover type of God lon
chay one of those fellows you know
Napoleon the third and he didn't he
didn't record isn't the register two
goals character he met him but he didn't
and he liked him for a little while
right during at the meeting but after
that he went right back to trying to cut
the goal down he wanted to shape Frances
state borders and also regime
to the war himself if you recall he
wanted a part of France become Vilonia
right he had that scheme and several
others that he and he wanted to go back
to parliamentarism of course the goal
didn't want that for Churchill but
there's a famous anecdote with Churchill
and de Gaulle Churchill is ranting to
one of his minister of one of his
colleagues about to go and then at the
end once he gets out of breath he says
well after all he is a great man given
the paucity of classical education and
in our country today I guess I would
hold true in our leadership as well does
it make you sort of pessimistic about
statesmanship for this nation well it
gives Hillsdale College something to do
no dr. Arnn will be here dr. Arnn will
be here next week he will teaching stay
crack I what I till I've taught a class
on fertile into Gaul at Hillsdale and
what I do is I let them be the teachers
in other words they are my superiors in
heart and mind and therefore the the
students should really learn from their
writings I do this not only with
churchland de Gaulle but with people
that I don't like very much I have a
course where I we do 20th century
founders so I have them reading Lannan
Wright State and revolution I have them
reading large swathes of mine calm I
have them reading the their here's a
famous 20th century founder for you the
Ayatollah Khomeini I have him them read
the Islam and revolution get it from
them you know politicians lie retail but
they tell the truth wholesale most of
the time
they kind of have to you know they're
forcing it so read them they'll teach
you and then as you as you one of my
colleagues professors Steve Smith is in
the English department was saying this
about the Shakespeare plays too if you
think along with you go all or if you
think along with someone like Churchill
as he's unfolding his argument in the
book or in a Shakespeare play you think
along with the different characters and
with the drama the argument of the
action of the book you learn you learn
how to think about these four elements
for example the regimes etc the state's
geopolitics you learn you learn how to
think in these terms and then you can't
get lessons from them you can't say well
you know here's what Churchill would say
today for America get that but you can
get habits of mind that can give you at
least a chance to start thinking in the
way they thought even if you're not as
good at it as they are no one was by the
way so you shouldn't feel bad about that
there oh yeah this is a little bit off
the beaten path but since some we are
talking to your political thinking and
since you're familiar with all of the
characters involved with the Second
World War I'm wondering if you could
explain to me a question that known has
ever been able to explain to me why did
hitler declare war on the United States
four days after Pearl Harbor what was
his thinking and doing what possible
benefit would he have in Germany being
at war with the United States I believe
that well I don't know you know I mean
no I don't know if there's any
documentary evidence about that is his
mind I'm a little bit hesitant about
trying to follow the convolutions that
all Hitler's thought um he certainly had
an ally was Japan right and he was
honoring his science with Japan for one
thing and if and yeah but he had a yet
he thought he thought he thought he was
he thought he needed that in that in
that part of the world he wanted to
support the Japanese he really did he
thought they were they were the Aryans
the Asians and so he had profound
sympathies for the for the Japanese so
so I so the answer is I don't know you
know I'm just guessing along with it
with it but it certainly was a
tremendous error wasn't it it made that
whole that whole controversy that
terrible America you know the america
first years versus roosevelt that bitter
bitter controversy which had herbert
hoover involved with that remarkable
book that he wrote that just came out
you know it was a bitter controversy it
certainly eased Roosevelt's ability to
to to to bring america in on the
European side
right that's another thing say so so he
wants t wants to knock out he certainly
wants the ability to knock out American
shipping to the Allies right and that
would that that's another thing he he
didn't quite learn the lesson of world
war one in that regard just one quick
comment he also thought of America as I
mongrelized the base country appreciate
what we really were that's another thing
he certainly underestimated America
didn't he and this is typical of the
enemies of commercial Republic's
generally and of America in particular I
mean America is oddly underestimated to
this day in some quarters America has a
lot behind it let me give you an example
of that this is one of my favorite
examples for the students some of that
my former students will remember this
one look at the way America is you've
got this continent-wide Republic it has
the biggest richest swath of farm this
is a georges friedmann stratfor type of
point I as the richer it has the richest
farmland in the world sitting in the
middle of it and it has the a huge
interconnected river system that flows
down to the Gulf of Mexico any country
as Friedman says who had that has that
is going to be huge and the the fact the
funny story with with Nikita Khrushchev
was that they took him up in a plane one
time is after all he's a Russian from
Ukraine he knows his farmland right why
would you like to see our our farmland
premier Christoph why da I've wood and
so they bring him up in the plane and
they and he's going along and he can see
satellite images but of course he can't
really see the quality of the soil from
a satellite image in those days that
kind of thing and he knows his farmland
he's looking at his eyes get bigger and
bigger as the plane keeps on going and
for the first time he could really see
I'm sure he remained confident that his
system was vastly superior to the rotten
capitalist system but he sure did see
the material this material strength of
the United States
it's on that day well my question going
back to church on de Gaulle as
Churchill's writings are incredibly well
known in the english-speaking world the
gall is much less so what is there about
the goal that we should read especially
in English they're all in English now I
would say certainly that book of the
enemy's house divided was his first book
that's a really that's a that I don't
think that's ever been surpassed in a
way as an analysis of the German
military I could be wrong that's very
good for his basic political principles
that the edge of the sword is his book
on that short book easy to read and of
course his two memoirs the war memoirs
right and three volumes and then his
incomplete memoirs of Hope which is
about his found really in some ways his
greatest act which was the founding of
the 5th fret french republic after all
France had been very unstable in terms
of his regimes for a long time and it's
been pretty stable since he did that
that was that was an accomplishment that
would have desperately needed to be done
thank you very much for your talk
professor Morrissey I sense a different
I have a difficulty with connecting this
sort of economic I'm an economist
economic progress material progress and
some kind of commercial Republic that
kind of dominates the world with the
idea of statecraft that these are
entities may be entirely different and
that somehow og economies don't fight
each other you know so I'm having
trouble connecting the economic paradigm
with the political well the don't forget
in montesquieu and in the Americans too
they don't they need they tend to say we
need commerce but we also need
republicanism in order to it countries
after all that have commerce with one
another they fought many times I give
you France and Germany Republic's have
bought one another many times but
putting the two together is is is is
conducive to peace with among those
countries among those types of regimes
so a a statesman who is interested in in
increasing the peace in the world is
likely to if he's the commercial
Republicans likely to want to encourage
commercial republicanism elsewhere and
of course as we all know commercial
republicanism has perennial enemies of
one sort or another we have plenty of
them in the world today
you